les prochains jours seront décisifs pour
le président américain en vue de sa
réélection écoutez à ce sujet andré
bercoff journaliste et auteur de
l'ouvragé donald trump les raisons de la
colère
aujourd'hui je pense que la situation si
elle ne s'attarde pas si elle ne dure
pas profil à donald trump dans la sens
aussi bon même lui avec ce côté un peu
braillard eu un peu comme ça comment
dirais-je très la jourre mation et
compagnie il dit bob gainey comme les
autres il faut attraper sa savoir pèse
pas kilos qu'il est aux manettes et qui
continue ça peut jouer pour lui en
revanche en revanche si effectivement
sur votre question si le débat du 15
octobre n'a pas lieu
je crois que c'est très très mal barré
c'est évident parce qu elles sont là
pour
pour la majorité des américains et du
monde ça veut dire qu'il sera il sera
pas capable de reprendre des affaires
avec avec la force et l'acuité qu'on lui
colle et c'est quel que soit ce qu'on
peut penser de trump l'été est là et il
il avait une énergie à revendre qui
effectivement et des malades et que
cette énergie banque ça va jouer contre
lui de façon drastique c'est clair